president joe biden now in the final
phase of his life has had several
significant conversion experiences
recently we we cannot quite call them
deathbed conversions but close enough
for one in the last few years he
discovered a belief in gender fluidity
though for seven decades or so he
operated under the firm assumption that
men are male and women are female he now
believes that menstruation and pregnancy
should not preclude a person from being
considered a man
this is needless to say a seismic
ideological shift
perhaps the most massive flip-flop in
political history really
and yet he's never been asked to explain
it
in a change nearly as dramatic biden has
also
decided lately that america is
systemically racist
now it's possible that he always
believed this but he certainly didn't
talk about it nearly as much
back then as he does now the privileged
white male biden has been in the system
himself has been one of the guys running
the system actually
for these past four or five decades then
he answered the 2020 primaries even
though there were several women and
people of color already in the contest
by winning the primaries he
intentionally prevented
all of those marginalized people from
having their shot at the presidency
he did all this while believing that
america is
is a systemically racist hell hole where
white supremacists prowl the streets
that black people are regularly murdered
by
law enforcement simply for existing or
else he only arrived at that conclusion
after he'd already knocked out all of
his minority competitors whatever the
case
it's clear that biden has undergone a
remarkable evolution
at this late stage of his life or at
least is pretending
that he has and this evolution continued
on tuesday when biden visited tulsa
oklahoma to commemorate the 1921 tulsa
race massacre
during his prepared remarks biden took
time to bravely denounce the kkk
takes a lot of courage these days to
come out against the kkk but he did
now it's interesting to note that he
didn't say any of what you're about to
hear
when he was delivering the eulogy for
his good friend senator robert byrd who
was a former clan member and organizer
didn't say that then but he says it now
here it is
if my memory is correct there were 37
members of the house of representatives
who were open members of the clan
there were five if i'm not mistaken
could have been seven it was five
members of the united states senate open
members of the klan
multiple governors who were open
members of the klan
most people didn't realize that a
century ago the clan
was founded just six years before the
horrific destruction here in tulsa
and one of the reasons why it was
founded
was because of guys like me are catholic
it wasn't about african-americans then
it was about making sure that all those
polish
and irish and italian and eastern
european catholics who came to the
united states after world war one
would not pollute christianity
the flames and those burning crosses
towards every region every region of the
country
millions of white americans belong to
the clan
and they weren't even embarrassed by it
they were proud of it
were there i i think were there people
in the audience shouting preach during
is that did i hear that correctly
it's an odd time yeah there were five
senators who were in the clan
preach amen
what now to further prove his wokeness
biden
also invented his own demeaning racial
stereotypes and announce them as
fact i hear this a lot from people on
the left they just they come up with
with stereotypes i didn't even know
existed for example did you know that
black business owners don't have
accountants
no i didn't either but that's what biden
claimed let's listen
that the data shows young black
entrepreneurs are just as capable
of succeeding given the chance as white
entrepreneurs are but they don't have
lawyers they don't have
they they don't have accountants but
they have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
i i had what black business owners don't
have lawyers or accountants where are
you getting that from
but all this clumsy pandering i think
really pales in comparison to the claim
that biden made at another point in the
speech about the current threats
posed by white supremacists listen to
this
as i said in my address the joint
session of congress according the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal
threat to the homeland today not isis
not al-qaeda white supremacists
some more oddly timed we'll get to that
claim in a second but
why are you applauding yeah terrorism
for white supremacy
is a lethal threat yeah what why is that
a
why is that an applause line i don't
quite understand it well really i'm
being facetious i do know
why people would applaud that because
that's what people want to believe
the most lethal threat to the homeland
now notice he doesn't say the most
lethal terror threat
there's no qualification he says it's
the most
lethal threat period he is correct at
least that we have heard
similar claims from the quote
intelligence community and certainly his
fellow democrats and backers in the
media echo this line or something close
to it
white supremacy is the boogeyman or
bigfoot
it's the monster that we're constantly
warned about though we rarely actually
see we're told that white supremacists
are lurking out there not just a threat
but the greatest threat we face yet each
day passes by
and all of the violence that the day
brings with it
has nothing to do with white supremacy
indeed the the majority of violent crime
in this country
isn't carried out by white people at all
let alone white supremacists
white people are vastly underrepresented
in the category of violent crime
especially among murderers
if white supremacists are the greatest
threat where are they
and what are they doing not much it
seems like
violence plagues our cities most of it
carried out by people who are not whites
and therefore presumably not white
supremacists
even the scourge of anti-asian violence
that we hear so much about is
predominantly an epidemic of racial
minorities
targeting another racial minority
i mean you've seen the videos maybe it's
not a coincidence almost
every single video we've seen
of an asian person being randomly
assaulted in the street it is a
non-white person carrying out the
assault
so where are the white supremacists
i mean it's just staying on the the
anti-asian thing for a second is
an epidemic of anti-asian uh
assaults whites they're there are
according to biden there are white
supremacists everywhere they're the
greatest threat
why aren't they doing any of this
why aren't they responsible for any of
it
people are killed every day in this
country hundreds every week
most of them in blue cities most of them
at the hands of racial minorities
yet white supremacists are the most
lethal threats something is not adding
up here it's like showing up
to the sight of a shipwreck and people
are drowning all around you
and you declare that the most lethal
threat they all face is uh high
cholesterol
the claim doesn't become much more
intelligible even if we limit it
specifically to terror threats biden did
not limit it to terror threats but let's
just pretend for a moment
that we are talking about terror threats
black lives matter and antifa
inflicted two billion dollars of damage
to our cities in one summer
dozens of people were killed hundreds of
businesses and lives destroyed
and the long-term effects have proven
even more devastating crime has spiked
across the country as police
leave the force departments are defunded
all because of the threats made
and carried out by black supremacist
radicals and their allies
black supremacy and left-wing militancy
is
far and away the greatest domestic
terror threat our nation faces
but all of this bloodshed and chaos
doesn't count in joe biden's estimation
because our government has decided not
to classify antifa and blm
as terrorist organizations it's as
simple as that
well they're not a terror threat if we
don't call them terrorists
they've decided not to even classify
their violence
as violence most of the time all of this
gets put in the
protest folder and then placed in the
filing cabinet and the drawer is shut
and locked
while swat teams are sent to chase down
old ladies who trespassed in the capital
on january 6th that's how biden and
company are able to
look at a country beset by violence
and blame it on people who aren't
actually committing hardly any of it
they do it by intentionally
miscategorizing much of it
and ignoring much more of it and simply
lying about the rest of it
and they also do it perhaps most
crucially by broadening the definition
of
white supremacy so that it's now come to
mean
all bad things that happen
now every bad thing is somehow in some
way
the result of white supremacy even if
almost none of it actually is
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated